so like a compassionate but heart
hitting gangster that you are uh recent
very recently you interacted with SBF on
uh I like I I just uh the suspenders as
you're saying this
um
you interact on Twitter spaces uh with
SPF
and uh
really put his feet to the fire uh with
some hard-hitting questions what did you
ask and what did you learn from that
interaction sure I should say first this
was not a willing interaction I mean I
thought that was kind of the funny part
of it because I've been asking him for
an interview for a while he's been
giving interviews to nearly everyone who
wants one big channels small channels
um he didn't give me one but I managed
to get some by sneaking up on some
Twitter spaces and dming the people and
like being like hey can I come up so I
didn't get him to ask everything that I
wanted because he like would leave
sometimes uh you know after I asked some
of the questions but really what I asked
was about this 8 billion and zooming in
on the improbability of his lack of
knowledge
um it's sort of like if you if you run a
company and you know the insides and
outs and you're the top of your field
top top in class
and all of a sudden it all goes busting
you say I had no idea how any of this
worked yeah I didn't I didn't know it's
like the guy who runs Whataburger saying
I didn't know where we sourced our beef
I didn't know where we that's a Texas
example actually thank you I appreciate
it uh let's let's take it like worldwide
Walmart like I didn't know we used
Chinese manufacturers it's like that's
impossible to become Walmart you have to
know how like how your supply chain
works you have to know even if you're at
a high level you know how this stuff
works can I do a hard turn on that and
go sure as one must to Hitler uh
Hitler's writing is not on any of the
documents around as far as I know uh on
the final solution so in in some crazy
world you could theoretically say I knew
I didn't know anything about death camps
uh so there's this plausible deniability
in theory so that's but that most people
would look at that and say uh it's very
unlikely you don't know especially if
all the Insiders are coming out and
saying no no of course he knew he was
directing us from the top I mean um what
was clear what's interesting about the
structure and like I love the knitting
yeah we're back to SPF yeah sorry now
we're back I wanted to turn us as fast
as possible
um I yeah I so the Insiders in what
Almer Alameda research what was
interesting is that there was this sort
of one-way window going on between
Alameda and FTX where FTX employees
didn't know a lot of what was going on
Alameda insiders and I would say by
Design knew almost everything that was
going on at FTX
um and so I think that was really
interesting from the perspective of a
lot of the so-called like what you could
which he's trying to ascribe to as like
failures or mistakes or ignorance and
negligence when looked at closely are
much more designed and they sort of
don't arise spontaneously because like
let's say so there's this thing in
banking and like trading where if I run
a bank and you run like a trading firm
we need to have informational walls
between us because there's huge
conflicts of interest that can arise
right so the negligent argument might be
that like oh we just didn't know we're
sort of these dumb kids in the Bahamas
so we shared information equally
but when you see a one-way wall that
starts to look a lot different right if
I have a back-end source of looking at
or sorry you're the trading firm so you
have a back-end way to look at all my
accounts and I have no idea that you're
doing that that all of a sudden looks
like a much more designed thing when it
would be plausible let's say going to to
use another another analogy too if
you're saying look I co-mingled funds
because I was so bad at corporate
structures you would expect those
companies to have a very simple
corporate structure because you didn't
know what you're doing right but what we
see with FTX and Alameda
is they had something like 50 companies
and subsidiaries and it's Inc impossibly
complicated web of corporate activity
you don't get there by accident you
don't wake up and go oh I designed like
this watch that ticked a very specific
way but it was all accidental if you
really didn't know what you were doing
you'd end up with a simple structure so
even just like from a fundamental
perspective what SPF was doing and like
the activities they were engaging in
were so complicated and purposely
designed to obfuscate what they were
doing it's impossible to subscribe to
the negligence argument and I want to
quickly say too like I don't think a lot
of people have honed in on this there
was insider trading going on
From alameda's perspective where
they would know what coins FTX was going
to list on their exchange there's a
famous effect where let's say you're
this legitimate exchange you list a coin
the price spikes
insiders told me it was a regular
practice for Alameda insiders to know
that FTX was going to list a coin and as
a company buy up that coin so they could
sell it after it listed and they made
millions of dollars how do you do that
accidentally yeah and that's that's
illegal totally illegal so that's
illegal from like and if an individual
does it it's illegal it's fraud what if
a company is systematically doing it and
you can't tell me that FTX
or someone at FTX wasn't feeding that
information about to Alameda or somehow
giving them keys to know that and that
would happen at the highest level it
would happen at SPS level and this is
why his arguments of I was dumb I was
naive I was sort of ignorant or so
Preposterous because he's dumb and
ignorant the second it becomes criminal
to be smart and sophisticated right
but then also coming out and talking
about it which is uh
it's a bizarre move it's a bizarre and
almost a dark move uh can you tell the
story of the 8 billion you mentioned 8
billion what's the 8 billion what's the
missing eight billion yeah so it's
really interesting because it's sort of
like wire fraud you sort of he's sort of
copping to like smaller crimes to avoid
the big crime the big crime is you knew
everything and you were behind it right
the smaller crimes are like a little
wire fraud here little wire fraud there
so what the 8 billion is is that FTX
didn't always have banking it's hard to
get banking as a crypto exchange there's
all these questions of like where's the
money coming from is it coming from
money launder so
for a variety of reasons it's always
been hard for exchanges to get bank
accounts so before when FTX was just
getting started they didn't have a bank
account so how do you put money on FTX
well they would have you wire your money
to their trading firm their wiring
instructions would go to their trading
firm it's easier to get banking as a
trading firm so you'd put your money
with the trading firm and then they'd
credit you the money on FTX
okay first of all this is a whole
circumvention of all these banking
guidelines and regulations
that's the first like thing that I think
is legal but
basically what SBF argued is that there
was an accounting glitch error problem
where when you'd send money to Alameda
even though they'd credit you on FTX
they wouldn't Safeguard your deposits
like your deposits would go into what he
called a stub account which is just like
some
account that's not very well labeled
kind of like a placeholder account
and
he didn't realize that those were
alameda's funds or they were playing
with those funds and that they basically
should have safeguarded that for
customers that's his explanation it's
Preposterous because it's eight billion
dollars but anyways
um just poor labeling of accounts of an
8 billion dollar account I mean it's a
billion a billion this is like doing
this all the time this is the craziest
thing like he was he was talking to me
and at one point in the conversation
he's like yeah I didn't have precise not
because he said I didn't have knowledge
of alameda's accounts and I said well
Forbes a month ago was getting detailed
accounting of Alameda and he goes oh
that wasn't detailed accounting I just
knew I was right within 10 billion or so
what is that error margin 10 billion
dollars for a company that is arguably
never worth more than 100 million yeah
that probably never never even worth
more than 50 billion
your error margin is 10 billion you have
to be this is a guy who is sending
around
statements that like there was no risk
involved and you're telling me he had a
error margin of 10 billion dollars that
is the difference between like a healthy
company and a company so deep underwater
you're going to jail so it you have to
believe that he is impossibly stupid and
square that with the sophistication that
he brought to the table it's an I think
it's an impossible mark